tornati su anita stone e per che cosa mi
è successo mi sono trasformata in un e
moggi in questo video
sarò un e musi quindi una me modi per
tutto il tempo che pino è troppo
divertente
innanzitutto fatemi sapere secondo voi
visto miglia l'unica cosa è che dalla
moglie oi capelli un po più corti vedete
purtroppo non ci sono i capelli lunghi
come mi è comunque oggi andremo a fare
una challenge che aveva già fatto che vi
è piaciuta tantissimo però per restare a
tema quindi a tema telefono e tecnologia
andremo a fare la challenge in cui si
sceglie come andrò pare lo slime è se
questo video raggiungere i 10 mila likes
andrò a fare un altro video in cui sono
univoci come che ne dite magari iniziamo
una serie è una volta a settimana farò
un video da e moggi che ne pensate
quindi ho già i miei colori qua e siri
andrà a scegliere gli ingredienti per
speriamo che non mi capiti questo che è
troppo divertente essere un emotivo sono
anche super espressiva che ho degli
occhi enormi wow è bellissimo allora
iniziamo subito abbiamo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 e
8 colori quindi chiederò a siri che
colore devo usare in sinni dammi un
numero random da 1 a 8
come non mai capito o missili
dimmi un numero a caso da 1 a 8 giri non
iniziare mi raccomando non litighiamo
anche in questo video perché non altro
video abbiamo litigato perché non mi
voleva rispondere
dimmi un numero a caso tra uno e otto a
ce l'abbiamo fatta
per fortuna non ha scelto l'uno che
inverte ma il 20 in glitter a torino ma
che dite di chiede un altro colore così
mischia ma i due colori ma speed dial
proviamo anche se un po rischioso perché
se vi capita il blu sapete che colore
esce ma vabbè rischiamo questa volta i
colori sono sette
quindi chi li amo essere un numero a
caso tra 17 tiri di un numero a caso tra
1 e 7 1
lo sapevo che non avrei dovuto fare
secondo colore ma perché
anche l'abbiamo ci sta trasmettendo la
mia espressioni tristi va bene sono
cercata ormai ho detto che avrei fatto
due colori e quindi ormai mi metterò
anche il verde c'erano così tante
possibilità potevo prendere il rosa per
piovola l'altro giallo e invece niente
ovviamente la maledizione del veste è
tornata qui miei due colori saranno
verde e giallo ok andiamo mentre i
nostri colori
purtroppo il verde che capita iscriverle
ovviamente però magari mischiato col
giallo e su qualcos'altro non lo so
vediamo
dobbiamo mettere innanzitutto il verde
pochi bene allora mettiamo più giallo
così forte e se di un altro colore
magari verde acqua
ecco fatto vediamo un po come diventa
sta diventando verde ovviamente non mi
sono salvate neanche questa volta dalla
maledizione del verde fate al centro
purtroppo di tallo magari campo
vediamo si sta schiarendo un pochino ma
niente è rimasto nardò non è detta serie
tutta colpa tua
ah beh almeno è un verde carino dai
evidenziatore deliberato cosa ne pensate
voi è arrivato il momento di far
scegliere seri la colla trasparente o
bianca questa bianche attesa in giù
perché è rimasta poca il nuovo parlare
vediamo cosa si ritiri dammi un numero a
caso tra 1 e 2
nessuna chiamata oggi con seri non mi
fare arrabbiare
dammi un numero a caso fra uno e due
blocchi wiphone numero 1 o numero due
disegni un numero a caso tra 1 e 2
[Musica]
ce l'abbiamo fatta quindi si riassetta
in due quindi la coda trasparente evviva
vediamo come riuscirà questo slime ok
aggiunge ballo software berte la colla
trasparente magari ora si schiarisce un
po speriamo
dobbiamo ancora aggiungere delle
decorazioni così magari anche con le
decorazioni cambia colore che mescoliamo
ed è rimasto bird e ovviamente forse
bianco lo avrebbe scritto un po in
effetti forse era meglio se si fa la
colla bianca ma vabbè dai non è male
almeno il super glitterato passiamo ora
alle integrazioni ed ora abbiamo la
lezione la schiuma da barba e una specie
di colla glitterata non è proprio con la
fa perché non funziona per l'online
comunque sono tanti glitter colorati
vediamo cosa s
e dimmi un numero a caso tra 1 e 3 c
mano ma come un numero che mi trovo in 3
50 seri insomma comportati bene
dimmi un numero a caso tra 1 e 3
ce l'abbiamo fatta
ok si riesce al numero ballo teorie
profumata andiamo ad aggiungerla al
nostro slime siccome questa nozione
bianca forte
cambierà un po il colore dello slam
speriamo mettiamole un bel po sarà
profumatissimo sicuramente allora
mischiamo un po tesi sta schiarendo però
è sempre verde e super profumato ma
sempre verde ovviamente dovevo mettere
la collana anzi maledizione del verde
che mi avete regalato agli incontri dei
firma copie del mio libro la prossima
volta la metto magari funziona allora
prossime decorazioni abbiamo delle
palline grandi blu poi delle fiches ball
celesti delle fiches goldberg di 20 mo e
poi questo che mi piacciono tantissimo
che mi avete regalato voi ai firma
compie che sono delle palline di colore
dei con dei colori bellissimi color
pastello io spero che capitino queste
quindi il numero 4 vediamo beni di mio
numero a casa fra 1 e 4 la risposta è sì
palline quelle che voleva inizio
capisci la stein francia e anche se
verde almeno tra un po di altri colori
mezzo
[Musica]
ebbene proprio i colori stupendi
grazie per avermelo regalate con qua il
bellissimo anche se verde ora a
tantissimi colori
non vedo l'ora di vederlo attivato
ora attendiamo altre decorazioni allora
numero uno
abbiamo dei glitter argentati che mi
avete regalato boy agli incontri numero
due
abbiamo dei pezzettini di frutta
tagliati frutta finta ovviamente
frattini i fruttini numero 3
abbiamo dei glitter rossi il numero 4
dei glitter ne vediamo cosa sceglie siri
per i seni numero a casa tra 1 e 4
ha scelto il 2 e quindi abbiamo i frutti
che vendono entra ancora più carino e
più colorato prima di continuare
sono curiosa di fare una domanda si
ritiene ti piacciono le memorie
dove ti trovi le impostazioni di
localizzazione attiva l'opzione infine
scorre fino a siria dittatura e consente
l'accesso alla posizione
cosa ti piacciono le voci sono più
simpatica da anita reali o meno oggi è
la tua e moggi preferita
mi piacciono tutte con è la potremmo
oggi preferita lasciate nei commenti la
vostra emoji preferita la mia e quella
nuova
il pappagallino pieris è più brava tu o
alexa non aspira alla grandezza ma
l'efficienza è più brava di alexa no era
una domanda allora un'affermazione a
letta è più brava di te molto divertente
ripensate di partecipare a un programma
tv comico ci speri molto male siri
sistemi molto male non mi piacciono
affatto queste categorizzazioni a vita
se li si sta arrabbiando meglio
continuare con la challenge sennò
continuerà ad arrabbiarsi dopo magari lo
facciamo qualche altra domanda
ora andiamo a mettere i frutti nel live
siamo come diventa ora è molto più
carino
almeno spero che lo sarà anche una volta
che lo attiviamo ecco qual guardate
quanti colori wow super carino che non
veda te questo slime melaverde sfruttata
o qualcosa direzione lo scrivete voi che
i commenti che i ragazzi ottimo lo slime
siete curiosi di vederlo e di sentire
che rumori a vediamo cosa ne pensassi lì
prima tv ti piace lo so in che ho fatto
bene cosa slime lo hai creato tu sei
contenta lui davvero creato to
scegliendo to i numeri non credo di
capire possa giocare con lo slime adesso
rimane una persona ricchezza di
competente in materia 76 un po
arrabbiata oggi di sei arrabbiata perché
ti ho detto che alexa è meglio di te sia
l'ex meglio di te credo ci sia
assistente che cerchi 6 meglio di alexa
vero usa ok lo dico davvero
meno male non se l'è presa perché in
genere litighiamo sempre
ora posso fare il po king stai dicendo
cosa dicendo ti senti ora vado a giocare
con lo slime ok ciao so se ho capito
bene ciao fili buonanotte
ok ok dopo aver parlato litigato e che
su scusa siri nuovamente anche se li è
un bel caratterino andiamo finalmente
togliere tutto la m dalla sotto lo
perché lotti fatto prima è una
bellissima consistenza anche se è verde
ovviamente la mia maledizione c'è sempre
[Musica]
e chi perde e verdissimo o è rimasto un
pochino appiccicoso padova mischiarlo un
pochino trova almeno a un sacco di
glitter e anche le palline ora che lo
faccio vedere meglio più che penso e
sembra proprio verde evidenziatore
guardate quanto è allungabile lo faccio
vedere meglio guardati un po è il verde
evidenziatore mia però tutte le palline
colorate
in glitter il fronti né i pezzettini di
frutta si vedono poco purtroppo non so
se riuscite a vederli che bello
a disp unisce barrett antartici però che
il vescovo li figli per allungabile il
criterio tentate di lime creato da siri
e dalla maledizione del verde perché
ormai è anche la maledizione del verde
che crei slime verdi vi è piaciuto crime
vorreste vedere un altro episodio in cui
io faccio qualche challenge qualche
flying scrivetemi pure i vostri consigli
se volete vedermi ancora in stile memo
je faccio anche anche vino lasciate un
bel light se volete vedere un altro
figlio di e di me e moggi a 10.000 likes
andrò a fare un altro video memo oggi e
ora vi lascio a quattro cartellini e su
cui cliccare per vedere i miei altri
video le mie altre challenge video
divertenti reazioni i nuovi video
cliccate su quello che preferite e buona
visione io continuerò a giocare
[Musica]